Zoom call. Welcome everybody to another Zoom call.
Hunter questions came in. So let's
jump right into it.
Revided to look on the member site. We have a question about
the
new commenter.
This is a good
better
but any new commenter will work. You can buy what at Target
or you all greens or something or you can order it on Amazon.
They're not very expensive.
And would it be advisable that everybody checks their glucose?
Maybe, maybe not. Again, you know, I don't want, you know, here,
you know, it depends on the person. So it, um,
you know,
I think, yeah, I think, you know, at the last you could feed the
cancer, the better off your, even, you have to have that balance on
what's going to bring you anxiety before it ought to, too. So
we'll just necessarily one more thing to do.
But check who goes can be beneficial. There's information on the
member site about that.
Remember, you have access to the courses and all the blog posts.
I do want to touch on this again this week.
It's right. You can send out an email, say that version 6.2,
now it's up to 6.4. So 6.4 is the version that's the current
running version.
But version 6.1, 6.2 and 6.4 is different than what
all of you have. I think, I think everybody on this call is
running 6.0. And, but those that started with us in the last few
weeks are running 6.1, 6.2 or 6.4, 6.4 just came out this week.
Now, there's issues with these. So don't think that you have to
upgrade. I do think that they are going to be improvements, but
there's some, there's some tweaks to it. You have to get to your
program a different way. If you go and talk, call to write, and
they upgrade your version to 6.1, 2, or 4, you will lose the
programs that I created for you.
And that's going to be a problem, obviously. So don't do that. If
you want to upgrade to a higher version, then please contact
us and you'll have to ship your computer back to us. And I will
have to upgrade you to the new software and put your programs
back up. And then they go on a little bit differently. You don't
see them in the main screen. The, as you open up the open home
program screen, you have to go to documents and then find your
program. So it's a little bit trickier. I do have a video on how to
get to your programs with the 6.1, 2, or 4 software. This is how
you would do it. I'm not going to go over it. This is on the
member's side. So let's get to the questions. First of all, does
anyone know of a good oncologist in the Atlanta area? We have
a patient that's moving to that area and wants to go to an
oncologist down there and find somebody who's open to, you
know, alternative-minded things, or at least open to, you know,
doing what the patient wants to do, not pushing a person just
towards what their protocols are. So please email me if you do
know anybody, if anybody's listening now, you can chat
in it, but otherwise email me so I can inform that person. I
appreciate that. Okay, how many days should someone back off
taking their antioxidants after receiving chemo? Are there any
other supplements that should be withheld for a time? So I do
have a blog post about this that gives you some general
considerations. Now, understand there are a lot of alternative
practitioners that say, don't back off at all doing antioxidants.
Don't change your supplement protocol at all. So, you know, you do
want to pray about it. You know, my belief is that, you know,
chemo is a strong as a strong oxidizing agent. And you know,
you want it to work as best as possible. So I do think you
should lay off your antioxidants at least for 48 hours. And
are there other supplements that should be withheld? Maybe you
could lay off all your supplements for 48 hours. There wouldn't
be any problem with that at all. You don't want to be doing a
lot of strong detox for that 48 hours because you want to
chemo to stay in you for that 48 hours and work and kill the
cancer. So you would not be a miss at just stayed off of
everything for 48 hours after that chemo. And if you're going
to do a fast prior to the chemo, you may stay off everything
during that 24 or 48 hour fast prior to the chemo. There is
nothing wrong with doing that. But I also don't think that
there's necessarily anything wrong with the approach and
other practitioners taken not to get weight off anything at
all. You just need to pray about that. My personal feeling is,
if I was going to do the chemo, I would go off the antioxidants
during my fast prior to the chemo. And then for 48 hours after
the chemo. And I wouldn't do any coffee enemas. And I would
do strong detox support and layoff of that. So I may actually lay
off of everything for that 48 hour window. And then you can go
back. A few weeks ago, I began taking black sand blood. So
black sand blood is a capsule supplement that has granola and
black sand and some other things in it per year recommendation
three times a day about 10 days after the first dose also
took water edema and had dead parasites in it. This caused me
to ask some questions. First, should I take a medizol for three
days in addition to blood root to kill any parasites? Or will
the blood root kill the parasites alone? So the parasites are
not giving you black sand blood root to kill parasites. So I
do not, I have never recommended a blood root for the purpose
of killing parasites and recommending the black sand blood root
for the purpose of helping your body kill cancer cells. So
that is the purpose of now. It is a half things in there that
can't help kill parasites. Sure. Can you take fed medizol
with black sand blood root? Yes, you can. If you're not
currently taking fed medizol, should you take it just because
you saw the parasites? I wouldn't know. If that's part of your
protocol, then I would stay on it and follow your protocol. Is
there a conflict of taking fed medizol and black sand blood
root at the same time? No. And should I stop taking any other
supplements before taking fed medizol? No. So you can take
fed medizol with all your other supplements as well. I read that
you aren't supposed to get IV vitamin C impusions if you're
taking Pectusol C. Can you explain? Can I just not take the
Pectusol C the day I get vitamin C? So I don't recommend this.
So I recommend that you take that you don't, I do not
recommend that you omit Pectusol when you're doing IV
vitamin C. Now, you can certainly upon, you know, what other
practitioners request, not take the Pectusol C the day that
you're doing the vitamin C IV. But I have never actually told
somebody to not take Pectusol C even the day that they're
taking the IV vitamin C. So I don't see the big conflict. I
think some of the research that it's not going to work as well
if you're taking IV vitamin C. But it's just the day that
remember, you take IV vitamin C. If you do take any
vitamins and have a half length in your body and it's going
to discreet quite quickly. So question of the cheek swam
the supplements from another practitioner. Do you agree with
the dose? So I didn't test the dose of those things. When
you get supplements from another practitioner, I don't
test the dose on that. That's up to your other practitioner
who choose to take that. I just test whether it, whether
I think it is advisable to case take that's whether a test
negative or positive. That's all I test when I test
another practitioner or something. You know, you can't
talk a lot about bags, but the men and dissolved, which is the
human cord of the Ben Ben dissolved is so expensive is Ben
Ben OK to take. We do have to look at the dose and equivalent
ice. It's 112 milligrams or something of the human
equivalent of that Ben dissolved. So yeah, I've never looked at
price difference for that. I don't think that the product
itself is that I could be wrong on it. I don't think the product
itself is any different. I think they're in the exact same
product. They just sold other different labels. So I think
you would be fine. That's my opinion. You think all the
reactions I had to the mistletoe could raise my liver and
that I'm so fast. The answer is yes, for sure. So anything
that causes an inflammatory reaction can raise your liver
enzymes actually pretty immediately. So yes, that's a very
big possibility. Yes, I've settings were OK. I did test
that from your cheek. So if I didn't change your right settings,
but it's in you a flash drive that there is no need to change
sometimes I could put no need to change right setting, sometimes
I don't actually type that. So you might not see. But if I need
to change on the cheek swab, you asked me to check your right
settings. I for sure did. And if I don't send you a flash drive
in there, there was no change. Can you comment on my chest
X-ray? Yeah, it was pretty but not so that your X-ray
what didn't show any horribly gross abnormalities. There was
some possible fluid and that's why the radiologist what he
uses those kind of obtuse words that that are difficult to
understand. It's because he can't be specific because there's
blurred margins and things like that that words that he used. It's
because fluids in there. So that I think you did send me
another question saying that you had a half liter taken off
your lung today, which is great and that will make you feel
better. I will, you know, is it word? Maybe this will be a word
of encouragement to this person. I've had people that have
had five liters of fluid and more taken off their abdominal
cavity and three more taken off their lung. So half a liter
isn't a lot of fluid that's built up. So that's actually a
good sign that is that that you got that taken out that you
don't get instantly from that. And it's a good sign that it
wasn't as much as your original thinking possible too. I
haven't had much cheese for such a long time but I'm
craving cheese. What am I missing? Well, I don't adhere to
philosophy that just because you're craving something that you
were always depleted in something. I crave cupcakes and I don't
think I have a deficiency in cupcakes. So it's that's not
always the case. So is it possible? Yeah, is it possible that
you're deficient in some minerals or something that you
would get from cheese? Maybe, but you are taking minerals. So I
doubt it. So I don't think it's I would always equate it to when
you're craving something that you're deficient in something.
I'm not he craved chemo pills. One of the side effects is
elevated glucose. You have he taking less burberry. Do we just keep
an eye on this? Yes. Yeah, let's just keep an eye on that.
In the testing, you came up with I think I dropped your burberry
down to one of the or something like that. I talked to my other
doctor that did the singotera test in June. It was over 1200 and
September was down to 550. Well, that's huge good news.
There's always silver lights and everything that's going on. So that's
good. While looking at options for breast cancer
treatments become apparent at a mastectomy, this is for
this person. Of my left breast would require a skin transfer
from my stomach to close the wound. So sometimes people don't have
enough flesh. The breast might be really small,
and they need to do a skin graft to close the wound.
Would a skin transfer trigger unwanted cell growth like
elective surgeries we talked about last week? Well,
any surgery is going to stimulate your body to need to heal from that
wound. So you just have to do what you have to do. So I think
having the lung surgery, they'll do the skin graft immediately to close that
wound. Yeah, I wouldn't hesitate to do that. You need
that one hesitate to do that. I've always had trouble detoxifying.
For the last two and a half years, I've been doing one to three
coffee enemas per day, which means I haven't had a
valve without an animal. Should I be concerned about that?
Should I back off the enemas and try different supplements to see if my body
will produce a little valve of it, if so which supplements do you
recommend? No, I wouldn't be concerned about that.
There is nothing wrong. The whole thing is that you have to be
limiting. If you're using coffee enemas on a daily basis, you're not
using them for the purpose of having the bowel movement.
You're using coffee enemas for the purpose of
stimulating your parasympathetics so that you
get all the benefits from that. That's going to help stimulate your liver
function. That's going to help clone your body. That's going to help decrease
anxiety. That's going to help decrease blood pressure. That's going to help
stimulate immune response. All these wonderful things that's stimulating
the vaginal nerve by doing a coffee animal. That's the whole purpose of it.
Beside effect, you could say I'm doing a coffee enemas, that it can stimulate
a bowel movement, but you're not doing coffee enemas for the purpose of doing
bowel movements. If you're getting stuff out of your body, if you're
having a bowel movement, whether you're using a coffee enemas or not,
that's all we care about. I don't care if you're having normal
quote unquote bowel movements without coffee enemas or not. Don't be concerned
about that. I'd stay on track with what you're doing.
You're doing so well doing with the coffee enemas. I would not change that
once. After a recent cheek swab, you recommend an increase in protein,
one gram per ideal body weight in clones today. Should I decrease fat
and or carbohydrates with this change in protein?
Well, you are going to be increasing calorie, so if you're
gaining too much weight, then that's an issue and you do want to decrease
carbohydrates, but that'll dig anybody in my patient base has that issue.
It's the purpose of decreasing carbohydrates would be to decrease your blood
glucose levels and decrease the fuel supply that a cancer might have.
So, no, if you're at normal body weight or a healthy body weight or if you're
under body weight, I wouldn't change anything.
As far as you're fat or carbohydrate consumption goes,
if your glucose is high and if you're eating too many carbohydrates, so that's a
different story. If you're under body weight, then you really can't decrease
carbohydrates at all. So, I would just try to increase that protein with
those changes. So, there's a lot of ifs in that answer,
but it depends on where your body weight is, where you're coming into this,
what your body weight is. Does the source of protein plant for
animal matter? Yes or no, there's nothing wrong with getting as much protein as
you kids through plant sources. It's just,
is a person able to get it up protein through non-animal sources?
It would be difficult, honestly. Is it necessary? Is it better to only get
play a protein? I don't think so, no. There's benefits to
animal protein. There's benefits for your red blood cells.
There's blood benefits for platelet count to get some animal protein in.
It's just a matter of having that balance and having good quality animal protein,
cooking the grass fed beef. It's so much better, so much more nutrient
dense and has good fats, good omega-3s in it versus
grain fed animals. So, try to get grass fed beef as best you can.
I know bone broth is not recommended due to the glutamate content.
Are both collagen and gelatin okay and do they qualify as a good source of
protein? Or would you recommend your protein powder instead?
Well, I don't recommend necessarily recommend any protein powder because any
protein powder you're going to get is only going to be 20 grams of protein.
And then there's a lot of filling up point on in that. Whereas if we eat a piece of
chicken, you're probably getting, you know, 40 to 50 grams of protein,
which is just as much filling up going on. So,
I don't, you know, and I just think that might be a better
bang for the buck if you can. Now, if you're using a protein powder,
I'd recommend the protein powder that we have because it's low in glutamate.
But back to the question about collagen and gelatin. Is collagen
the gelatin okay? The answer is yes, but you have to be careful with it.
Collagen can have glutamated it. I don't know the content depends on the type of
collagen that you're using. But collagen does have other
possible issues with autoimmune issues. It's not that uncommon.
Yeah, so you might want to test it. So, I mean, do you feel better or worse when
you're taking collagen? So, try to, you know, ask that question
with collagen. It's not that, there is a way I ask, it's not that uncommon for you
to develop anybody's collagen tissue. We see that with autoimmune patients.
I mean, it's not super common, but it is a possibility. So, do watch and see if you
have any reaction and inflame increase inflammation
to collagen. Gelatin two, so if you needed to know these things,
collagen is tested on the Cyrex array five and gelatin is tested on the Cyrex
ten. Those are just possibilities. So, just be careful of that.
Don't try to look if you're taking those things. Make sure you note if you're
increasing inflammation after you take them. You mentioned the glucometer
pass. So, Miles, do you recommend one for each of us?
Should we all be trying to keep our glucose levels below 80?
Well, the answer to that is yes and no. I don't think everybody has to do
everything. It depends on the person. So, I just, you know,
talked to somebody that I think is on this call that we talked about just
just kind of laying off on that. Don't get too anxious about
measuring glucose levels. That could cause anxiety with some people.
So, we don't want to do that. We don't want you to be
anybody to be so hung up by their diet that they have
anxiety around it. You do your best to eat the best you can
and to follow a protocol without making it
a god in your life. And you know, that sounds awful, but we can tend to do that
with things. Especially when we have serious illness, we can get a little
obsessive about stuff. And I don't want you to get obsessive
about measuring your glucose levels on a daily basis either. So,
yeah, I have a glucometer. I often do I check my glucose, not very often.
So, and why? Because I don't obsess about
those things. I've said in the past, my diet is
probably worse than everybody that's on this call. That doesn't
mean that's the right thing to do, but that's not something I
obsess about. And, you know, what I feel convicted
about eating something or something. I'm consuming that I just
back off on it and try to get back in balance. It's a lot of times I go
out of balance the wrong way, but for the for I don't it's easy for
some people to become out of balance in an obsessive way. I don't want you to do
that because that just leads to anxiety and anxiety. What does
anxiety do to us? The anxiety just shuts down our parasympathetics.
So, and we need our parasympathetics to detoxify. We need our parasympathetics to
have a healthy immune response. That's the whole idea. And that really is the
whole idea about trying to increase your protein levels
because if those are your building blocks for your lymphocytes and your lymphocytes,
your T cells, your natural killer cells, which are lymphocytes subsets,
are what kill cancer cells. So, that's the whole idea of
saying that. So, even when I say try to get your protein levels up to the
to the, you know, grams of protein per body weight, what your desired body weight is,
instead of something you need to obsess about, you necessarily need to
cult on a daily basis either just go, oh boy, I just want to kind of look at
my I guess I am only like 30 grams of protein a day. I need to bump that up. I
need to start eating some chicken or some beef every day and
and get that up there. You don't need to necessarily
count it every day and be obsessive about it. I don't want that for anybody. We have
to stay in balance and keep our focus on doing what's right.
But our focus shouldn't be on the the acts of doing right. Our focus needs to be
on our heavenly brother and just ask him to develop that relationship with him and be asking him
to convince you about what you need to tweak and what you need to change and what you need to do.
And you use guidance through, you know, us and me as best as possible and
honors and and you don't love to become
anxious or obsessive in anything that you do, whether it's
dietary or something that's or anything. So just
guarding you against that. Last week we answered a couple questions for me regarding
electrically recharging depleted cells. So if we missed last week we were talking about
cell, your cell membranes hold a charge that charges
measurable actually. That's called your phase angle to measure your you can measure your phase
angle for those who you know, days below by, used to come in our office, used to measure your phase
angle. You mentioned the PEMF was good technology to assist with this. I have a beaver. A beaver is
a PEMF machine. So that I have been using twice per day, more than an evening. I found two interviews
on your blog library referencing the beaver and your guests categorize it into the category of PEMF.
That's right because the beaver is a post electromagnetic field. It's called a low ghost,
post electromagnetic field machine. My doctor recommended it to improve microcirculation,
but does beaver also work to electrically recharge depleted low voltage cells.
The answer is yes, that's exactly what the beaver does. That's exactly what a PEMF machine does.
That's really the benefit made benefit of a PEMF machine. Two water questions and a mineral question
today context. A relatively wide recently spent two weeks at the carfield clinic for colorectal cancer
treatment. While there, the clinic provided alkalized water produced by a kingkin machine.
In researching your site, I found two articles where you discouraged the consumption of alkalized water.
Number one, if one is consuming a healthy diet, clean, balanced, organic, not factory
process, and not relying on alkalized water to compensate for an otherwise poor diet,
is there benefit to consuming slightly alkalized water produced by an ionizer?
Number one is that should I use alkalized water at all? This alkalized water
alkalized my body. That's really the question because you've heard that cancer
grow in an alkaline environment. Cancer grows in a acidic environment. That is kind of better
dogma in the alternative world. Number one, I totally disagree with that. Dogma, I totally
disagree with that statement. Cancer does not grow because the environment is acidic,
or does it stop growing because the environment is alkaline?
Cancer is growing because the cell is defective in the DNA replication piece.
That's why cancer grows. So, something got inside the cell,
damaged the DNA. It goes into rapid replication and replicates cells that are rapidly replicating.
And the rate of that replication is the speed in which the cancer grows, the rate in which
the cancer grows. So, and a quote-unquote aggressive cancer has a higher replication rate.
Maybe it's replicating every day. Maybe it's replicating every hour. That would be very aggressive
cancer. So, or maybe the cancer is replicating very slowly. So, and our goal is to stop it
from replicating or to slow the replication cycle. You're slowing the growth of the cancer.
That's the idea. Though anytime cells are rapidly replicating, they're highly metabolic.
Take a lot of energy. It takes energy in order to do that. When a cell produces energy
and inside that cell is a warehouse of different small little organs called organelles
that do different things. What is mitochondria? Are organelles that produce energy?
Well, it also produces a lot of waste. So, that waste is then exited through the cell membrane
and into the extracellular space where the lymphatic system then carries it away. But since cancer
is rapidly replicating, it's producing a lot more waste typically than your lymph system can carry away.
And when the cancer is producing a lot more waste, that waste is more acidic typically. So,
cancer is growing in an acidic environment because it's producing an acidic environment.
It's not because it's acidic that it grows. It's not something outside the cell that's causing
the cell to grow and to replicate. So, that's a medical model. You know, it's not something outside
of you that's causing a problem, it's something inside of you. Same thing with the cells. It's not
something outside in the cell that's causing the problem. It's something that's inside the cell that's
it's causing the problem.
What I've been doing is in the case of cancer.
So, but it is producing a lot of acidic waste.
So, is it good to alkalize my body?
Well, yes, well, how would it alkalize a cancer?
Well, I would increase the ability for that cancer
to, for that site where the cancer is growing
to be able to detoxify.
So, how do I help lip flow to the area
and lip to drain that out?
So, there's not a waste layer of acidic waste layer
that hinders my immune system's ability
to get lymphocytes and natural killer cells
in there to kill the cancer.
Well, you need to help with detoxification pathways.
And you don't just detoxify through the lymph.
You have to, that lymph desk to be carried back
to the blood stream the arterial system, the venous system.
And then that goes back to the liver and has to exit
through the liver phase one, phase two, phase three pathways
and then through the gut and then to the toilet.
So, that's why I wrote seven phases of detoxification
to help understand the chapter go through that process.
It might drink baking soda, which is much more alkaline
than alkaline water.
Is that going to help alkalize my tissue site?
Well, yes, if my cancer is in my lower esophagus or my stomach,
but is that, but the idea is you have to detoxify.
You have to get rid of that acidic slime layer
in order to be able to get things flowed
so that your lymphocytes can get in there.
So, it's not just a matter of changing the pH of the area.
It's a matter of getting rid of that detoxify there.
So, even if I have stomach cancer,
would it be advisable to drink alkaline water,
would it be advisable to drink sodium by carbonate baking soda?
No, I don't think so.
I don't think the purpose is to change the pH of that area.
The purpose is to help get rid of that waste,
not to change the pH of it.
I think the fact that waste is acidic
is really a non-issue.
Besides the fact, it's just like a physiology.
If I drink baking soda, if I eat baking soda,
I would be alkalizing the stomach.
Is that even advisable?
Drinking alkalized water and alkalizing my stomach
and defeating the purpose of my stomach
sells the bridal cells in my stomach,
producing hydrochloric acid to digest my food
and alkalizing my stomach,
which is increasing the risk of Hylori infection
in my stomach and in my duodenum.
And increasing the risk of Hylori in the gut,
which then could spread throughout my body,
which Hylori is the top five causes of a coronary heart disease
and arterial spiralsis.
It just doesn't make it tricky.
Alkalizing your stomach makes zero physiology sense.
However, it's zero.
So I just totally in disagreement
with using alkalized water.
Just I just, I don't, I'm stepping on a lot of toes,
but it just does not make any physiological sense
to me whatsoever.
And you're actually probably producing more ill health
with a person.
Now the question's gonna go on here
because I have to answer this point.
However, two, one of the other advertised benefits
of the Kagan system is that it pumps the water full of hydrogen.
Now that's a totally different game.
So hydrogenated water is totally different
than alkalized water.
So this machine may actually hydrogenate the water too.
I have all four using hydrogenated water.
So if you want to use hydrogenated water,
all four of them.
But there's machines that use hydrogenate,
that will hydrogenate your water
without alkalizing your water.
So I would highly recommend that
if that's something that you consider.
Now I don't, I don't tell people to go get a hydrogen water.
We were into that for a period of time
and then all first came out.
It's, it can be costly to get a machine to do that.
And I don't know completely the benefits.
I know the one machine that I just got an email about yesterday
or the day before that they did some internal studies
with cancer patients and saw some benefits.
But I have to take a closer look at that.
That's a different thing than alkalized water.
So yes, I have got a fan of alkalized water
and not a fan of drinking baking soda.
But it's so, and you can look about H. Playlorion.
I think I just did a couple of long calls and all that.
I work at heart a grow deed at avoiding EMFs,
but I want to do everything I can.
Good last week you addressed a question
about mineral supplements and advocated the clear multiband.
I found that there's also a clear multiband plus
on the store.
Okay, so the difference between clear multiband and clear multiband
plus is that clear multiband plus has a few other things in it.
And one of the things that clear multiband plus has in it
that clear multiband does not is iodine.
Now, there's a lot of controversy about iodine.
So if a person has hypothyroidism
so they have to give low thyroid.
It's classified as either primary hypothyroidism
meaning that they have low thyroid production,
but they do not have an autoimmune thyroid
called Hashimoto's.
So if you have antibodies to thyroglobulin
or TPO antibodies that are elevated,
then you have Hashimoto's or Graves
if you have hyperthyroid.
So those people in this thyroid category,
anybody with primary hypothyroid Graves or Hashimoto's
should not take iodine.
Now we know again, that's controversial
because almost every alternative doctor
and many, many mainstream doctors
will tell people to take iodine for their thyroid.
However, study after study after study has come out
and people have not read those studies.
And if you want to go into detail about iodine and thyroid,
go to the courses and go to the autoimmune course
and look at, I think it's the module eight
that's all on the thyroid and I go into depth.
So I'll let you look at that yourself.
So I am recommending that you do clear multimin,
not the clear multimin, books.
When you were sick, did you go through a period
where you had energy until you got up
and took everything you had just to do
your daily routine of life?
Yeah, I mean, I had days where I was absolutely wasted
and I couldn't even sit at my desk and do work
and I had to sit down in a lazy boy chair and relax.
So that's what my staff do
that I was not doing well is what I was doing
as therapy in my office when I was supposed to be working.
So there was a lot of days like that.
So yes, can there be reasons like having fluid on your lungs
or having fluid a sighties built up
in your abdominal cavity that couldn't cause that?
Yes, can there be other reasons like anemia?
That's the most common cause of fatigue
is overwhelming fatigue is anemia.
So you want to investigate those reasons.
This is the same person that asked the question I believe
that just got their lung drained and so I'm curious.
And do you feel like that's any better
after getting that done?
I have been doing high dose vitamin C
and first I felt so much better the next day
in the last three or four weeks, I feel worse.
The hand is more swollen under my ribcage.
Liver area is really swollen or sore.
You think this is affecting the cancer
because I have spots on my liver.
Why would it bother this far into the treatments
as I've been doing them since July 50 grams
was doing twice a week down once a week?
Because your cancer could just change
and sometimes you just have to,
you have to change up therapies.
So you might have just reached a plateau of dosage
that your body can take and you're not detoxifying it
so that you might actually be getting a toxic dose.
So when you're doing this high of grams,
you think, oh, vitamin C, that's fantastic.
You're getting 50 grams in, right into your bloodstream.
You might lose its benefits
when your tissues are completely saturated
and you're not able to get that out.
And then when you take another dose
and you're already saturated,
that can be pressure on your liver.
Remember what I say,
what I've always said too much of a good thing
can be a bad thing.
So to me, if it was me,
just I'd pray about that and say,
maybe I just need to calm down a little bit on that
and just back off on that.
We'd stop doing it for several weeks to a month
to see if your body just kind of settles out
and maybe do want to get in another month or so.
I'll just calm down on that
because you might just kind of be out of toxic dose.
Brad, due to connoisseptic membership,
welcome going into surgery tomorrow.
Is the advanced healing program
the best for surgery recovery?
So I think you're talking about the right programs.
I do have, we have a dog blog post on surgery.
You might want to look at that
because there are some specific right programs
you might want to follow after surgery.
Also after watching the right tutorial
and frequently asked question videos
the information is a little conflicting.
You say you want people to snuggle with the hammerball.
Zero to 18 inches away from them in bed.
Jason, I think you mean Jake at Stadeford, Jake at Turing.
It's Jake.
With true rife says that the Jack Hammer amplifier,
the effect of the hammerball
is magnified 256 times
and it can be placed under the bed.
I would prefer the under the bed approach
since I'm a late sleeper,
but I have a sizable tumor
with lung metastasis, your recommendation.
So understand many, many of the videos
that I have made over the years
was prior to true rife coming out
with the Jack Hammer amplifier.
This is a new piece of equipment as of last summer.
So prior to the Jack Hammer amplifier,
I told everybody you should just snuggle with your right ball.
You need to snuggle with the ball.
So, but I, personally, I don't use the Jack Hammer.
I just keep, you know, I'm just snuggled with my right
and I snuggle with my right every night.
It's just things on my stomach every night.
And most people in this call,
probably in that same situation.
We didn't start including the Jack Hammer
until just last year when it came out.
So a lot of people don't have the Jack Hammer.
Most of my patients don't have this piece.
Do you need it?
No, however, if you want to sleep
with the ball under the bed, then you need it.
So if you have it, you can sleep with it under your bed.
You put it under your bed.
So that is the conflicting information.
Well, it's only conflicting
because you're using another piece of equipment.
So if you add the Jack Hammer to your ball,
then you could put the ball under the bed.
You don't have to sleep with snuggle with it.
And that will solve your problem.
So yes, that's exactly what you can do.
Can you talk about caster oil packs?
I have all the materials, but have it hesitant to do it.
How do they work?
How do they help someone with cancer?
Especially is cancer, if cancer is in the liver.
So I recommend caster oil packs over the liver.
Mainly, mainly that's all I recommend
is the user caster oil packs over the liver.
Caster oil packs just help the flow,
they'll help decrease the viscosity of the bile.
They're my helping the bile flow
through the colon bile duct
and into the gallbladder it out into the tomato.
So that's how caster oil packs work.
Even if you have cancer in the liver,
even if you don't have cancer in the liver,
they help move things through the liver.
So yes, go ahead and use them.
We can have instructions in your manual.
I recently got a GI map and mycotoxin test resums.
GI map, no H by lower issues.
That's good.
Opportunistic bacterium balances, yes.
Staph aureus, streptococcus,
low levels of secretory IgA, and occult blood.
So this is inflammation in the gut
and you have some bacteria in the gut.
So I have to look at your protocol
that I have you on first of all,
but I'd probably be thinking of
endographis and gerberine for these.
What I would do, your cult blood has to do
this person has colon cancer.
So that's to be expected.
But I would think that those are the kind of things
I would think of with this.
The mycotox test shows ocotoxin A, high,
but not showing any no mold at your house.
So the mycotox test doesn't test for mold at your house.
So I did sue you, you're saying
that you don't notice any mold at your house.
You really want to get some mold plates
to see if you have mold at your house.
If your ocotoxin test is high,
so where you get ocotoxin A, ocotoxin.
So understand, again, the mycotox test
is not testing for mold, it's testing
for the toxins that mold produces.
So when you have high levels of ocotoxin A,
that means you were exposed to a mold that produces
that mycotoxin.
Now, that mold that produces that mycotoxin
is commonly found in some foods that is very commonly
found in mold that would be in buildings
and in your home and things like that.
So it is probably the most common mycotoxin
to be elevated because we're often exposed
to mold in homes and buildings in schools
and everybody's bedded as, especially school,
I could still smell the mold in my memory of my school
when I was at grade school.
Yeah, in my case, there's no mold in my home
that I'm aware of, but there's a meditation hall
in the field house where I take kids to play
that is loaded with mold
and I had to actually leave that place
and couldn't go there and I haven't gone back
for probably over a month now.
Okay, so when you have elevated ocotoxins,
that end of the toxins of that mold production.
So you still have to detoxify those.
So those are poisons that that mold produced
that are in your body still.
So the reason why you get your home tested
and get your, you know, you can smell them
and you can, you kind of got a pretty good idea.
You have to do that investigation of,
okay, where did I get this?
Cause I don't want current exposure
cause if you're going to detoxify that,
that I like, that's what I like about our clear talks product.
If you're going to detoxify that and you have current exposure,
well, you know, you're never going to really detoxify.
The toxins that mold produces are poisonous to everyone
and they can really make us ill.
And ocotoxin A is a cancer causing agent.
So pulling that out of your body,
but also, you know, making sure
that you don't have hidden current exposure.
So if you, like you said,
and you went to these certain places
and you could smell molds, you had to exit those areas,
do not go there again.
And maybe inform, you know, higher powers
than they should get that clean up
because other people are getting sick too.
It's not going to be just you.
So these are very dangerous things
and not just just because they're our carcinogens,
but they can make, they can cause inflammation in the brain.
They can cause all sorts of really serious problems.
So mold is a serious issue that needs to be dealt with.
So detoxing it is the thing.
So you're detoxing.
These are poisons.
This isn't the mold.
This isn't mold in your system now.
It's the toxins that the mold produces
that's in your system
and you detox it with key layers.
So, and binders.
So really, any binders and any key layers
can really help pull these things out.
And I didn't look at your, your phone call,
but you might already be on some of those things.
So I'll look at your phone call tomorrow
and email you.
I think there's anything else for you to change.
Thank you.
Dr. Thomas Simfried, author of Cancer as a Metabolic disease
promotes the ketogenic diet
and at time glutamate restriction to not feed cancer.
He has coined the term metabolic ecology,
thoughts on this approach.
Seems he has excellent results
and affects cancer cells and others.
So yes, so understand ketogenic diet again
is something that's your strongly restricted
any glucose in the body.
And that's the balance of, you know,
looking at getting a glucometer
and measuring your glucose.
Now, in, if you're getting truly into ketosis
and your goal is to get into ketosis,
you can't just use a glucose monitor.
You have to use a ketone monitor
that it gets a little trickier
and there's a little bit of a learning curve
to learn how to measure that
and to get yourself into ketosis
if that is a person's goal.
Most practitioners, though believe like I do
that it's not even necessary to get into ketosis.
Really, if you could get your blood glucose down below 80,
you can do the same thing is what he is doing.
Matter of fact, there's some research that's going on
right now through a group that by follow
that is using Dr. Thomas
as a member in the research group
and that's what they are finding.
So even under his guidance,
they are actually finding you get the exact same benefits
as trying to get into ketosis
as just getting the glucose levels down.
Now, understand, it could be hard to do.
I mean, it is very difficult to stay on a ketogenic diet
and it is even more difficult to truly stay in ketosis
and most people end up giving up.
The younger you are, the easier it is to do that.
As we age, it's even more difficult
to truly get into ketosis
and it can be difficult as we've talked about
on these Zoom calls, even eating a pretty perfect diet.
Many times it's hard to get your glucose levels down below
100 for some people because glucose is not just a product
of your diet.
It's a product of your cell membranes
and it's a product of your pancreas.
So there's a lot of different pieces to the puzzle.
I've had over the years I've had diabetic patients
that would go on a full ketogenic diet
and they still, I was just mind boggled
that it's not eating any glucose
and any carbohydrates whatsoever.
And we couldn't tear glucose levels below 150.
So it was like, gosh, it's more complex than that.
Now the younger a person is trying to do that.
It's a little bit easier to do.
Should I be taking glutamate as a supplement?
No, absolutely not.
It's really a glutamate restriction that you want to do.
So glutamate can feed cancer in energy.
You don't want to take glutamate as a supplement.
Especially, it's even more important not to take glutamate
as a supplement if you have colon or colorectal cancer.
That's the epithelial cells in your colon
prefer glutamate or replication.
Questions on the chat, I have to cutters.
Today I learned that Dr. Hancock will likely take me
as a patient because of my situation.
Good news.
I'm here with his office.
I learned about Dr. Ready.
And I'll invite an ecologist in the Atlanta area.
So our moving plan is going forward.
Praise God.
That's fantastic.
I have noticed a couple of times lately
while holding on to my right bulb
that I become electric during certain parts
of the programs.
When I touch them, when I buzz and slightly shock them,
is this usual and safe?
Yes, it's very usual and very safe.
So it does can give you an electrical charge.
So we talk about adding, this person was talking about
trying to use a PDF to increase cell charge.
Well, your right does increase cell charge too.
You are getting some electrical benefits with that.
If I have chemo in the afternoon,
is it okay to do a flip-back in the morning before chemo?
Yeah, I'd say no problem whatsoever with that.
Sure.
I had my first chemo, one of three, three weeks apart.
Last Wednesday, I have some side effects,
but I feel much better than I would have expected.
I can tell that the detoxy makes me feel better
and I am grateful.
However, I can feel my kidneys as well as
a weird air-track pressure at times.
Might be getting bogged down.
And should I be using other or additional detoxy?
I am doing half over our sauna.
Two of these coffee animals, castoral impacts on the liver,
beamer 40 minutes a day, footpath three to four times
a week, rebounder a few minutes a day, supplements.
All these are good, maybe adds a little bit of mild exercise
that can be good for the brain too.
So yeah, you're doing well.
Making sure you're drinking putty of water,
having all good bowel movements.
Do you recommend filtering city tap water?
Absolutely positively.
You do not want fluoride, you don't want chlorine.
Two poisons fluoride is just criminal
that they're still put into the water system.
You definitely have to get that out.
You do not want to be drinking that.
What filter do you recommend?
You can use reverse osmosis, you can use a burky filter.
Typically a simple carbon filter will take out the fluoride
and chlorine, but a carbon filter will take out heavy metals
if you have heavy metals in the water.
That's where you have to use reverse osmosis.
Some people say, well, reverse osmosis causes dead water.
It doesn't have any minerals in it.
Yeah, but you're not drinking your water for your minerals
in the minerals that you do get in your water
or our earth's bound milling minerals.
They're not the type of minerals that are good for you anyhow.
So that whole argument just does not hold water.
I'm not kidding.
Our water would come from Atlanta, you know, to get out.
I would, I'd recommend reverse osmosis.
We have reverse osmosis here at the office.
Even though we have well water at the office,
test it higher than nitrates, nitrate.
So we have a reverse osmosis here.
Our water at our home is well water
and we tested it and it's good.
So we do not have filtration here at the office.
Would it be good to add charcoal powder to a coffee?
I don't know.
You know, you can.
I don't know that it would be really beneficial
because your coffee atom isn't going very high up
in your testicle tract.
So not really not, so you're not going to absorb that anyhow.
It would hurt, but caught your joke, dark Jake at St. Berk.
Sorry, I stayed with the jackhammer
and the bulb right next to me
because I thought I was supposed to.
I zapped my wife a lot and left one to shut.
Well, that actually makes like a little more fun.
So that's good.
So yeah, if you ask that question about putting it under the bed,
if you have the jackhammer, then you can put it on the bed.
I was going to ask if there was anything preventive
one from snuggling with the hammer bulb,
and connect it to a jackhammer.
No, except that you are getting a higher amplification.
So you will end up with this problem
that people are talking about to people today
that you're going to produce more electromagnetic electricity.
So you're going to have a charge.
Electromagnetic, so when you rub your feet against the carpet
and you touch somebody and you give them a shock,
it's because you have more electrons on the surface
on your skin.
And it is the same thing with if you use the right,
you can develop electrons on the surface of your skin.
So when somebody touches you, they get a shock.
If you're using the jackhammer,
you have an amplification of that.
So you will actually produce more electrons,
especially if the bulb is right next to you
and you're using the jackhammer.
So some people don't like that.
So I understand I'm joking that it brings a little fun
to your marriage, but it's not very pleasant.
So personally, I don't use the jackhammer
because I've got used to snuggling with the bulb.
So if that bothered me, if the light bothered me
and stuff, I would just use the jackhammer
to put the bulb underneath me while I slept
and then that would solve that problem.
The only caution I've seen is not to touch the jackhammer.
It's not a problem as the frequency cheddar
is under the bed.
So that's just fun.
You really don't need to, if you have the jackhammer,
you don't need to snuggle with the bulb.
So are there things I should be doing to combat
any potential autoimmune issues
that might be happening due to the ketruda?
Well, you can't really combat them
until they happen.
So most people that are gonna take the mutal therapy
like ketruda, that's one brand of immutal therapy,
are gonna end up with an autoimmune issue.
You just can't prevent that.
Because the whole, what immutal therapy does
is it blocks the receptor site on the T-cells,
on your T-cells.
So your lymphocytes break down into natural killer cells
into T-cells.
And that's when it kills kids or are those two things?
Well, the T-cells have a receptor site
that your human body cells attach to
and then it tells the T-cells not to kill your body cells.
So what immutal therapy like ketruda does
is it blocks that receptor site
so that your T-cells will kill the cancer.
Well, they'll also kill your human body cells
and you'll end up with autoimmune diseases
so you could get any type of inflammation
that those cuddling will be colitis
while you're on T-cells.
So you just gotta deal with it when you get it
and just try to heal the colon and you can't necessarily prevent it.
Thank you for the admission to not obsess about diet.
I struggle with that.
Thank you for pointing us back to the word.
You're very welcome now.
I have a reverse osmosis system in my kitchen
with minerals added.
We are out of well.
Should I continue with the minerals?
It really depends on the source of the minerals.
So I would have to know the system.
I know some of those systems have like a tube thing,
like a filter thing that adds minerals,
but they're really crappy.
Sorry, crappy forms of minerals.
Remember your minerals should be as if you're eating vegetables
or grass-fed beef,
or grass-fed meats and chicken.
Those minerals are double bonded to the amino acid.
So that's why I do not recommend the liquid
for minerals that are out there.
I don't recommend a lot of the most of the products
you can buy at Target and Walgreens and stuff like that
because they're just garbage minerals like E dirt.
We are not created to eat dirt.
We're created to eat the plants or eat the vegetables
or eat the animals that are eating the plants and the vegetables.
It's already broken down by the plants
to a double bonded to an amino acid and then we eat that.
That's how we absorb it.
So it's a mineral canister added to the RO system from the company.
I would give rid of that.
See if you can eliminate that.
It's definitely just mineral.
It's definitely a first one mineral.
So I'd give rid of that.
One of the symptoms of colitis and the red might
it become active and noticeable.
It would be just pain in your gut.
Colitis is inflammation of the gut,
so you could have pain in the gut.
You could have pain after you eat.
You could have
blood, yeast, stool.
There's different symptoms.
Credential serious the colitis is.
Again, don't focus on what could be.
So if any admonition I could give all of you
just to kind of keep your focus on the Lord.
And yes, if something happens,
then we'll deal with it and ask you how to deal with it.
You can ask me how to deal with it.
But don't focus on what could be,
what might be in a bad sense.
Focus on the possibility.
Paul had punished us in first Corinthians.
There's anything that's good,
anything that's holy,
anything that's right,
anything that's worthy of your admonition.
Focus on those things.
That's, you know, the world is horrible all around us.
It's easy to get our bad eyes off of Christ
and our eyes unto the problems.
Let's not do that.
So that's, that's, that's, you know,
notish each other daily to keep our eyes focused
what's positive, what's good, what's holy.
And work out those things.
If you're getting some stuff at crappy,
after you eat them,
then, then make sure you're getting digestive enzymes.
Make sure you're, you know,
you have lots of supplements that you're taking.
So just, just look at anything
that could be irritating your stomach
and tweak your diet around that.
Thanks, everyone, for the prayers.
My double best deck to be read smoothly.
For the next day, I felt worried
other than just uncomfortable.
Everyone around me says it's because I mean,
it's such a good shake.
I've been doing my program this last year,
now onto the next phase.
I'm grateful that went well.
Praise God, it's a good note.
And don't know that I'll be prayed to all of you
and I do just ask that you guys pray for each other
and keep your focus on what I'm
Christ and all that he's given us
and be grateful and thankful in all things
until next week.
We'll see you then.